What is going on everyone welcome to a data visualization?
With python and Matplotlib tutorial series, I'm going to be redoing this series
I have an older version of this series on this channel, but it was actually one of the first series
I ever did and it could stand to be updated quite a bit
Especially as that we get into the more advanced aspects of using matplotlib
So here we go. We're going to go [ahead] and update this series. I'm not going to release this series like I normally do
[where] I do like one video a day I'll be releasing this series in Rather large
Chunks at a time and the reason for that is a series doesn't really have to be followed linearly the [first] few introductory
Tutorials you if you're not familiar with Matplotlib you probably should follow along linearly
But then from there
you should be [able] to make your choice [into] kind of what kind of topics that you're
specifically interested in by that same token a lot of times I
release the series first and then I go back and puts put the
text versions of the Tutorials on Python Programming net
And and this time I'm planning to have everything released all together. So you should be able [to] get the source code and
The videos at the exact same time and then you can go to python programming at net and kind of figure out
Which of the main topics you're mostly interested in what you're looking for and all that so anyways in this series
we're going to cover everything just you know from the basics of
Graphing graphs with matplotlib you know your typical scatter plots and line graphs and bar charts [stuff] like that
And then we'll get [into] a bunch of the customization options things like plotting date time doing fills
having multiple plots on the same figure and
Shearing axe use all kinds of stuff like that. We'll talk about base map, and we'll talk about a little bit of live graphs and
Then we'll talk about 3D graphing and then that will pretty much round out the the series
So feel free to bounce around if you don't [know] the basics kind of stick around for the basics
But otherwise you should be able to kind of bounce around some stuff will will reference like will teach Legends
And then I'll show you how to customize legends and then later on we may actually customize legends based on a legends tutorial
So for that reason [you] might want to fall linearly, but you shouldn't have to so anyways first things first
How do we get Matt plot lives so there's you know a few different ways that we can go about actually acquiring?
Matt plot lives, so the first way would be via your command prompt okay, so cmd.exe
you should be able to go there and
let's open up that and
If you have python 3 or a new version of python 2 this tutorial is going to be doing python 3 and using python 3
But feel free to use [python] 2 if you want just understand there's some changes. You'll have to make and [I'm] not really going to
touch on those so first of all the easiest way is if you have a 32-bit version of python which you do have if
If you just installed like the default it doesn't matter what your operating system is you might have [a] 64-bit version of windows?
unless you try to you have 32-bit python if you want to check you can always just type in you know python and
read at the very top here see my [python] is a 64-bit, but if your says maybe 32-bit, then you have 32-bit, so
Just to quit here, so to get matplotlib the easiest thing to do is pip install
Matplotlib and that should be it if it says pip is not a recognized command, then you'll have to give the full path
So on windows that would be C colon slash if you have you know for python and then the version I'm using 3.4
So we would say python
34 Slash scripts
Slash pip install
in the matplotlib
[okay]
[that] should be good enough
Later on you might find that it says you don't have a module and there's like a few of them like
Let's Say 6 6 comes up a lot people
Go import Matplotlib, and it says no module named [6]
Well you have to get 6 to any time it's python says hey, you don't have this module
You need to get it. This is how you would get it same way
You got matplotlib so go pip install 6 [ok] and that would give you 6
So that's what the command prompt
Next we could use
Scope here [we] pull over a new tab and you can go to Matplotlib [Gorg]
Matplotlib org for some reason whenever [I] could in matplotlib gorg I get a lot of times like this
Website like it's like it's down all the time
I don't know what the deal is there, but anyway you can come to matplotlib org scroll down to downloads
[we'll] click on the [mat] plot libs downloads page, and then here you get two downloads for
64-bit and 32-bit
Windows you can also get the wheels you can install files with wheels
[but] if you're on windows, just get this or this right win32 would be for 32-bit [one] 64
or when amd 64 for the
64-bit, there's your os x images and
Linux you would just install via the source
so
Once you have matplotlib
You should be able to
Import Matplotlib without a problem so the next thing that we're going to go ahead and do is to show a really simple
line graph with Matplotlib
So to do that and to use matplotlib the first thing we need to do is
Import the Matplotlib but
more specifically what we use is Pi plot and pi plot is the main kind of
Functionality that you're going to be using all the time, you're pretty much every application
I can't think of one that is not going to be using [pi] plots. So you're going to do this a lot
so you're going to need this import mat plot lib pie plot as
P Lt. We do that just to shorten it and
That's a standard so most people shortened pie plot as p lt. So if you're looking at other people's code
You can kind of you'll understand that you won't have to usually trace that back to their import, so you'll just know p LT
It's kind of like with numpy people important um Pi as nP everyone does that so it's a good idea to do that, too
So people can understand your code when you need help, so
Import map outlived up pi plot as p lt. And that's fine the next thing that we're going to go ahead and do is
Is Plot?
so when we go to plot
we invoke the pi plot module which we say is [pl] [t] and then we say dot and plot and
when you go to plot, you plot x's and
You plot wise now we don't really have anything for x and for y, so
Let's fill those in let's just create two lists so we'll say x is 1 two three
And then why you didn't pretty much say whatever you want we could save fives not 76574
[okay], so [our] graph does something interesting case, okay?
So we plot there and then now what happens with graphics is
Everything is drawn to a background first
And then when everything is all ready to be shown that's when we bring forward whatever has been
You know we've been working on the background Matplotlib is no different
So in the background this graph has been drawn, but we need to bring it to the Forefront
So the way that we do that is just with a simple plt dot show empty parameters, and that's it
So now we can save and run this
and
I suppose we wait for a moment
Here we go, and there is our graph. So we'll be talking a little bit more about how this works
[but] basically you know you've got this graph. It's a line and you've got like this kind of a Gui window that you have
And then you've got these buttons down here so we [can] run through those buttons real quick
First of all you can resize the graph no problem
You should be able to move that around a lot then you've got these first three buttons
We can't really do anything with them just yet. So we'll talk about those at the end
we'll start with this little cross here if you click that you can now click on your graph click and hold and like drag the
graph round a little bit
Okay, so that's one thing then you've got like the zoom so you can zoom in [to] a specific area if you wanted you can
also zoom out, so that was with a left click and hold to draw the
Triangle you know the same thing by right click and hold and this instead will zoom out. So [we're] able to zoom out that way
Then you've got configure subplots right now this doesn't really mean much to us
But we can move a few [things] like you'll notice there's a lot of empty space on the left
the right the bottom and the top we can kind of we can use this to adjust that space and
Later on we'll use it because you can actually
Program in these values to change them so we'll talk about that when that comes up
Then you have this save of the figure
This is just so you can actually save the image or even a vector of the graph and a bunch of other options, too
then we go back to
These buttons so first you've got this little home that will return you to the original
View so you click that and [now] you're at the original view everything's back to normal
You can use the back to previous view to go back one you can keep hitting this and keep going back
Conversely you can go forward right and go back to the original views before that
So those are the basics of Matplotlib hopefully you guys are up to this point if you have any questions or comments
Please feel free to leave them below otherwise as always thanks for watching thanks for all the support and subscriptions and until the next video